Speaker 1: I want to look at them just to kind
of a I don't want to say this is the final kind
of coda on this story, but we're kind of closing
the loop on this classified documents thing that
we've been covering regarding Donald Trump. Glenn
Kirschner, a legal analyst, said on MSNBC that
Donald Trump is facing a five year felony over the
classified documents scandal. As you now may know,
we've covered it a couple of times. Donald Trump
did indeed take classified documents to Mar a Lago
to his house. Those were since recovered by
the National Archives, and the full story has
been turned over to the Justice Department for a
criminal investigation. Here is Glenn Kirschner
appearing on MSNBC, talking about the legal
liability here. And remember, faces five years
is very different than something will happen.
Speaker 4: But let's listen. Glenn,
the judge's ruling says quote to deny a president
immunity from civil damages is no small step.
The court well understands the gravity of its
decision. But the alleged facts of this case
are without precedent. Your reaction? My
reaction is Donald Trump may be reaching the
end of his rope, I agree with Paul that there
is, I think, a hesitation among prosecutors,
both state and federal. Nobody wants to be
the first one to charge a former president
who's committed any number of crimes. I
predict Jonathan, once the first brave
prosecutor who has the evidence to indict Donald
Trump, brings that indictment. Everybody's
going to want to be the second prosecutor.
Speaker 1: So that's that's interesting first
and foremost because we've been talking about
this. I guess we might say hesitation to kind
of crossed the Rubicon because there's this again,
it's not a policy. It's sort of just like a, um,
an unspoken agreement. I don't even know what to
call it. There's this tradition of not charging
American presidents, current or former. But this
is a unique circumstance in that there are so many
different reasons why Trump might get charged. But
yet I think Kirchner is right. Kushner is often
hyperbolic. He's made predictions that haven't
come true, so I think that all with a grain of
salt. There is some degree to which it makes sense
that no one prosecutor would want to be the first
to charge a former president. Then let's move
on to where he talks about the five year felony.
Speaker 4: Glenn switching topics just a little
bit. How can the Jan. six committee use the
information that Donald Trump took classified
documents to further its investigation? Yeah,
that is a five year felony, the National Archives
has reported and referred to the Department of
Justice for investigation. The fact that Donald
Trump removed classified national security
information from the White House and he whisk it
away to Mar a Lago. Jonathan, if that were you or
me or Paul, you can bet we'd already be indicted.
Speaker 1: Now that part is absolutely true for a
number of the different things Trump has done.
Normal people so-called would absolutely have
been indicted already, but again faces a five
year felony is very different than anything
is likely to happen. I would love it if the
evidence points to charges and a conviction
for Trump. I would love for that to happen
if that's what due process determines. But I
still do not believe Trump will see any jail or
prison time period wake me up when he actually
faces some consequences. He's been dodging all
sorts of legal entanglements for. I mean, listen,
certainly the five six years since he started
running for president, but even longer than that,
when you consider the Trump Organization and at
a sort of basic gut check level, think about the
absurdity of Trump as president has the ability
to declassify anything he wants. He could have
just declassified the stuff that he wanted to
take. He doesn't. And instead, he just takes
it without declassifying it. And now he has stolen
classified documents. The most logical explanation
that I've seen is the documents are worth more
still classified. They're worth more money. But
that's a crazy explanation. But it's
also the most reasonable explanation
in the sense that what Trump did doesn't make
any sense. Will he face consequences? I doubt it.
But there are now multiple criminal
and civil investigations Georgia,
New York Justice Department looking at
the documents. The stuff with the Trump
Organization. And the misstatement of the values
of assets. This it's going to be years. And
maybe Trump's best bet at getting out from under
all of it is to run for president in 2024 and win,
which is yet another reason why we have to
be prepared for him to try to do that again.